what's up with your headset what's up
with your old face on ders
or should I say blunders honey why don't
you go back in your area I just saw you
lick your microphone well you didn't was
that just my office space you're
intruding my office space right now oh
my god that's good
no Dada Dada Oh looky here mr. cold
turkey put a mini booze bottle in his
headset I really like your ingenuity but
destroys the prototype no way that's
right you know many minutes or tinkering
that took me but to be like seven
minutes to make we took an oath all
right
yeah you're not special I am special
that's why I took all those special
classes in a high school why do you
think you can boss me around huh
Slim Shady